[Music]
Hello, welcome to Chat in the Arena, the
weekly podcast where we recommend and
exchange ideas about content we've
read, listened to, and watched, always bringing up
product discussions. I'm Artur, and this
week's owl, I'm... and Olympics,
just Olympics, and then this victory
for Brazil today too... Oh
my God, bye Spain! Damn, did you
see that the Spanish girl scored? Ah,
we played against a team that, in my opinion, doesn't
play football, they lost 4-0 to a team
that doesn't play football, imagine if they did play football,
exactly! So, we wanted to
do a show just talking about the
Olympics, today I think it's the only thing
I'm capable of talking about completely.
But we're actually going to
talk about some other things too.
We're going to do a news roundup, there's a
lot going on, and Nvidia
caught piracy and
illegality red-handed, that's it, but before the FTA there's advertising, there's
no shortage of that here, right? It could be the
Olympics, it could be before, before the
Olympics, it could be the World Cup, etc.,
there's always our little advertising campaign, gold medal
in advertising, gold medal in advertising, day
20, 24 of...  In August, two
weekends from now, two or three weekends,
we have the fifth edition of the
critical and analytical thinking workshop with me
and Dudu from RD, and on
September 14th we have the fourth edition of the
AI ​​for PMs in practice course with me and
Efren. Iira will also be there, as
always, talking about the GPTs he created.
Both courses are live online, and
that awesome exclusive discount for
listeners is in the link in the description. Okay,
now let's get to the agenda. Let's go!
[Music] Okay,
to start the
news roundup here, I think the
good news is that they decided to release the cloud
here in Brazil. Cláudio Claud... I don't know,
Cláudio is
Cláudio clud. Claudinho, Claudinho is
now available in Brazil too. Damn, finally! It took
so
long, man! It took forever to
learn Portuguese! Yeah, and of course
we tested it, so we could talk a
little bit here. I'll give my perceptions
here. Man,
I liked the onboarding before you
could type, and I had...  I had
the same impression when GPT
was launched, which also had a whole
tactile aspect. I don't know if you
remember in the app, it was kind of
writing things down, etc., before you
started using it, and the phone would vibrate and stuff. It
was a really cool experience.
Now, with Tropic, before you can type
or ask any questions, it also
gives you a description, asks you to
accept all the terms, asks
you to put your name, and so on. It
says what you want to be called, how
you want to be called, tells you that
it can make mistakes, etc. So, I
liked the guided explanation, you know, a
literal onboarding process.
I liked that
process too. It
takes you to the experience of
starting a chat, right? It doesn't just throw you onto a
screen, make your prompt, and that's it.
I don't even remember what a PT chat boss was like back then,
but I liked the Cloud one
too. I thought it was cool. I did it in the
browser, not in the app, but
it was the same experience. Another point is that
it's more expensive than GPT. And
then
I discovered that I was paying more for it.
GPT here, because I was paying in dollars
lately, so here's a tip: it's exactly right,
a tip for anyone who was a sucker like
me: if you subscribe through the App Store
it costs R$
99.90, and if you subscribe through the
Open website it costs $2, and that costs a lot of
money every month, that's exactly it.
So today I'm going to cancel
my subscription and resubscribe
here somewhere else, but anyway, in terms
of price, the cloud is 110 plus fees. If
you do it through the web and the app it
's also cheaper, it's R$
109.90. I won't make that mistake again, but
I won't make that one
anyway because I'm not going to subscribe to
two chats and other things like that. I
have a spreadsheet that I generated in GPT,
which I always use
in courses and to test
tools and stuff. I tested Basic, it's
a spreadsheet that has some numbers and the
name of the
product, the revenue he sold, like the
value he sold, and things like that,
very simple. And then I asked
him the same questions, like, "
With this spreadsheet, what D..."  The analysis
we can do by comparing the results of
GPT with the cloud only
brought different orders; it brought the
same points—10 points here—it
brought the same points, just in different ways.
But the cloud brought more context to
each of the points it
could analyze. You know, I felt that a bit
in my test. I did a test that
wasn't planned, but it ended up happening.
I wanted to see, I wanted to do an analysis
of the last quarter results from Amazon. And I
wanted to know specifically how much of
Amazon's revenue came from
ads. So I downloaded the PDF, put it in the
cloud, put it in the chat, and I feel
that the response—both gave me the same
answer. I feel that Claudio's answer
is more substantial; it
seems less concise
than the GPT chat answer when
you ask a question there without any prompt, a
very
direct question. Another thing that I think is
a very visible difference is that
GPT already brings, already processes graphs and
spreadsheets, already brings these formats in the
answers, while the cloud doesn't. It
literally brought texts there for me.  It
was broken into bullet points and
all that, but it's text, isn't it? It doesn't have
an image generation model,
like ChPT has Dali, and I
think that's a big part of it
for everyday use, especially
if you're not doing something very
specific in terms of code, which they say
Claudio is very good at, or more
creative work, which they also say Cloud
3.5 is very good at. I think
ChPT is still the best because it
gives you more functionality in the end for a
very similar price, right? I mean,
we just discovered that it's
cheaper, in my case, which was a
very similar price, but it gives you, in addition to
a top-of-the-line model, also an
image generation model, a
data analysis tool, and
so I think it still brings a little
more than Cloud brings to the
standard user. Yes, I even
asked him after he generated it, "Hey,
can you generate a graph for
me?" And he said, "I'm sorry, but I
don't have the capacity to generate, create, or
manipulate images directly. I'm a
language model designed to
process and generate text, not to create
visual elements like graphs."  It can't
do that via code, so that's
it. However, it can
offer guidance on how you
can create this chart using
popular tools like Microsoft
Tabloid, Python, and even
R. But it's the PT chat,
when it generates a chart, you give it a
spreadsheet, and it generates a
chart. What it's doing is running the
code behind the scenes, right? It's
not running, but it already gives you the image ready-made.
So Claud doesn't do
that at all. Claud only brings
the listed things. For example, it doesn't
have a code processor. I asked it a
question about this spreadsheet I
sent, saying, "Hey, help me calculate the
total revenue per product." It
literally put: number one, product,
value, total value; number
two, number times quantity equals value. And
GPT, on the other hand, gives me a spreadsheet that
I can
even download.
So that's one of the things I
saw. Good, I haven't tested
this part yet; I need to use it more in the end. I need to
test it a bit more
here. And then, I think other things, just to
summarize here, it doesn't generate
images, right? You can't send
audio yet, and have...  This conversation and the analyses you're
putting together are all in text, right?
Like I already said here, good. And since
you mentioned sending
audio, let's start talking about OpenAI.
One of the new things this
week is that they started rolling out
Advanced Voice mode, which is the one
that generated all the buzz at
their event, with much smoother conversations, it
felt like you were actually talking to a
human, being able to
interrupt and stuff. So they said it's going to
start arriving for everyone who
pays for OpenAI Plus. It hasn't arrived here
for me yet, I think it hasn't arrived for
you either, right Artur? No, no, I
even did some extra digging the day they did it to
see if it was there, but not yet.
Sad, but I'm anxious to use it. I
'm seeing some videos on Twitter and
YouTube of people using it. I think
for those who like to talk
alone it will be wonderful, I'm one of those
crazy people. So I think it will help
to stay here sometimes exchanging ideas and
saying things out loud to help reach
conclusions, I think it will be a good
companion
here, I don't know if you have this habit sometimes,
I  I call people on the
work chat and I say, "Hey, can you come into
the chat real quick, just to do a
quick check, just PR, to see if what I
'm thinking isn't completely
crazy?" And then, while you're talking to the
person, you can actually reach the
conclusion you wanted. It's great,
I used to do this a lot
with Lucas, he participated in the episodes here,
we always do it a lot. Let's go,
Demis. "But hey, I just wanted to see
if I'm not crazy, okay?" "And then,
let's see the next ones, when they're released
for us, we'll bring updates
here too." But as always, this
happens every week, right? There are some
movements there, even the co-founder left,
right? Every week there's news, it's
like Big Brother this thing. So
this week there was the departure of one of the
co-founders, right? And he's going, you know, to PR, to the
competition, he's going to mess with
Claudio's father,
and the
president listened to the podcast here and
remembered the work, work, work,
but don't forget that commas
mean
pauses, that's what he said.  That's
it. And then he asked
Samo, "Hey buddy, I'm the president
of this company, I'm going to take a
sabbatical." So the president
of Open also left, Greg Brockman, right? Exactly,
he told Samo, "Stay here, I'm going to take
a break." And just to
say, John
Schuman, who led the Post
Training team at Chat, left. So he's going
to
Anthropic. What he says in his tweet is
that he wants to get more
technically involved there, to go back to doing
more technical research. But I think it's a
big move, a guy who's a
co-founder, leading one of the super
important parts of the company's product,
is going directly to a
competitor. And he specifically...
he specifically says, "It's not that...
it's that he wanted to work more
on AI alignment, that is, he ensured the
safety guards of the
Artificial Intelligence." And he says, "It's not that
Open doesn't care about that anymore, that
a lot of people who took care
of the safety side left, but it's
because..."  I think there are some cool people
at Tropo, I think I'll be able to get back to
having one, it's a more technical approach, but
I think it's more someone in the line
who handled things more focused on
alignment and safety and who is leaving the
company. At the moment, there's a
lot of talk that Open is looking less and
less at that, right? It's more like
our guys at Open
got up to something, man, they went and
launched search, right? They announced that there
will be
GPT search. And then, you know, Microsoft didn't even say anything, right? It was
last week, and Microsoft, which is one of
the biggest investors
there, has now listed Open as a
competitor. So, will we have a
breakup and end of relationships? Ah,
I think that's unlikely. This one seems more like, "
Hey antitrust guys,
we're not a monopoly." I didn't read it,
but it seems that yesterday or today
a very important Deon came out,
considering that Google has a
monopoly in the search business, so it's
a business that's super hot in the
United States, right? And I think it seems like
a move to position ourselves as
not creating a monopoly, we're not
that, so yeah, I think there is.  There's a lot of
that nowadays, but even
if they're competitors, you
see, Google and Apple are competitors, they
also have partnerships, right? So, I don't
know if you can call it a
partnership when one pays billions of billions
of dollars to the other
to have their search engine as the
main product. But okay, I'd
say it's a negotiation, not a
partnership. Oh, but it's a negotiation, and well, there
could be other partners. Right? There
could be partners, exactly.
Anyway, and what else, and I think lastly,
here's a bit more nerdy for
developers, especially, but
also for us in product, right? Today, on the
day of this recording, Tuesday, OpenAI
announced structured outputs
in the GPT chat API, which is nothing more
than when you're making a
call to the API, being able to guarantee
that a structure, that is, that
you pass there for the API to use, will be
respected. So, one of the main
use cases, they even talk about this in the press
lease of GIP as a whole, is to take
unstructured data and structure it
in some way, right? And until now, there wasn't
a way for you as a developer to guarantee this.
So developers
had to do several things.  Well,
not makeshift solutions, but using various
tools to try and guarantee
that, and with this new possibility, they
said they had
100% success, that the API was
returning the passed structure. So
I think that greatly facilitates applications of the
Open API, in this line of
transforming unstructured data into
structured output. This helps a lot
when building things, a lot.
And I think the last pending
news update here, actually not even
news, it's just an update that my rban
continues to work here in Brazil,
they forgot, they forgot the flag was on,
they forgot the flag was on. So I
still don't use it for much, but
the coolest thing I did,
actually, was
with Lucas testing it too, was
counting the number of Funko Pops I had
on my shelf. You can't
see it here, but Artur's background
is his shelf of Funko Pops, and there are
many Funko Pops, in fact, and even I didn't
stop to count them, and there are
almost a few.  40 here, 30-something, and he
said, "Man, there are approximately 34, I don't
know what," then I counted, really.
So, there you go, I'm bringing up its
great use, and if I have more uses,
exactly, great use, congratulations. That's it, that's it.
[Music] That's it. In
this second segment, we're going to
talk about Nvidia, which was caught red-handed
using protected content to train
a video model they're
developing internally called
Project Cosmos. A ton of
messages leaked, a company document,
so a lot
of conversations
they were talking about downloading and using
YouTube videos for training,
Netflix movies, Discovery
Channel movies, and besides those things, there's also
a series of datasets they were
using for training that aren't
released for use in
commercial applications, which is what they were
doing. There are even messages
explicitly from them saying, "We're not
doing research, we're not going to publish
anything, we're actually creating something
here that will eventually be a commercial model." I
even found it interesting that
they say, "Oh, movies are excellent
ways to generate content for games,
right?" We have 3D models for games, and...
So, Nvidia has a
huge scope of things they work with,
so they were making a leap to
accelerate this training. What I
found interesting about this news, besides
the controversy itself, is that there are several other
controversies that have arisen in recent
weeks about companies training models on
content they shouldn't. The discussion
I wanted to bring to the table is how we,
product people and lower-level executives
in general,
should proceed in situations like
this, where there's approval from
management. There are also
screenshots showing management saying it's okay to do it, go ahead,
no problem. So,
someone at the top is saying to
do something that is legally wrong and
ethically questionable at the very least. And I
think that with the increasing use of [something unclear - possibly "Aid" or "Aid"],
more teams and people will face
similar needs.
Many times we won't even be
thinking about whether or not we can use
certain content for
training. So I think there are several
examples of product managers giving
opinions and making decisions related to
this. I think this will become
increasingly common in our daily lives
working with products.
Model training that many companies will have
is definitely expensive, and the report is
full of printouts and gossip with quality, right?
Congratulations on the 404 Mia day,
look,
and covering some names, very good,
congratulations, you can't say it did
n't happen, right? So much so that
Nvidia's responses weren't like, "it didn't
happen," "we're here, we
believe that our use is Fair," so
they are taking advantage of the
gray area of ​​regulation, let's say, and
that thing, right? As Charli Brau would say, "Every
choice is a choice, that's life," right? So, like
Charli Brau, Snoop, no,
great Charli Brau, Chorão, man,
imagine, in the line of what, there are only
two points of view, I think one
is the internal one of who are the people
working there to create this, and the other
is the external one of who will
actually use it, you know, that thing, many
times you say, "Okay, I sell
my data," I know that when you
accept the US terms, you
're
signing that your life will be exposed
there, probably, so for the
end user, how much of a
problem this use is, I don't know, but  I
think it will obviously bring to the
forefront this issue of, like, "Wow, how are
these things being trained?"
And I think it
's a problem, especially for creators,
right? I think many
YouTube creators complain, "
Man, this shouldn't be being trained."
There's even this discussion
in the Envid chat: "Oh, they're not... we're
downloading 8 million
videos. They're not making money
from the ads that would be shown on
these videos. So let's run this on
Google Cloud, which we're paying for, at
least for the
data." Apparently, it
was an old data they had for something
else, not this until
now. So I think there's this perception.
A small percentage of users will
say, "I'm not going to use it because of this," right? There
will be that, there will be that users will
want to delve deeper, but the vast
majority want to
use it internally. And then, my friend, there are also
factors, right? There's this raising of, "Man,
this is really strange, we can't
do this here." It would be like, "Man,
we want to use
this, but we can't, we can't." There's
something that...  Hey guys, can you make
some kind of loophole here so we
can do this? I can see
this situation happening, just like with
startups, right? I think you must have been through situations like this too, where there's
often a situation where there isn't a
rule saying you can't
do something, but there isn't
necessarily a rule saying you can either.
So, many times, even in discussions
with the team or compliance, you might think, "I'd
like to do this, is there a way we can
do this?"  I think the best
league teams I've worked with, including the ones I've worked with,
were these facilitators, not in a way that cut
corners, not in breaking the law or anything,
but in finding ways for us to
do things so that we could
stay there, you know? Totally. So I think there's
that point, and the other is,
everyone has their principles and their bills
to pay. It's up to each person; each one
will be able to say, "This violates
my principles to the point that I don't want to
work here anymore because of this," and
other people will say, "Oh, I don't
agree, but it's falling apart here," and I mean, don't attack me,
attack me. So
I think a very wise decision,
even by the report, is that they hide the
names of the
lower-level employees, the lower clergy, and I think that
's true because,
in fact, the person in charge isn't the one
making the decision to do that; they're
finding ways to do it. But again,
I think, a PM, you as a PM are
thinking of a way to operationalize
that product, right? And you have other
teams to support you in relation to
that, right? If you, along with your...
Okay, you can
go ahead, the risk is there, there's no risk, or the risk is
this, along with other stakeholders,
you decide, make decisions, man, it's part
of life, right? I think a lot of the decisions
we make in product development on a daily basis
are risky, in fact, right? They're not
certainties, and I think again what
you said, right? There are things that...
ethics isn't binary, right? It's
not like this is ethical or this isn't
ethical. Ethics is up to each person, and it's up to
each person to assess whether that thing
is endangering them in some way or not.
You think, "Damn, man, this isn't
a crime," I don't think that
necessarily violating a terms
of service constitutes a crime, right? Or
more misuse, a bad practice, but I
think the clergy can't be held
responsible in these cases. They
have to decide if it makes sense to them
or not, right? It's a tough situation,
I want to go through it, let's see what the next
steps will be, right? But
that's a big deal...  I wanted
more gossip from other companies doing
this, with so much evidence and
sordid details, like
screenshots of messages on Slack. I think it's
really cool to see
corporate communications from other companies like that.
There's a Twitter account, I think we even
talked about it here, that releases
emails between companies, yes,
mainly between CEOs, directors, and so on, which
usually come out of trials and
such that these companies are involved in. And it's
really cool, man, to see, like, the
directors of Apple and Google
talking about hiring
each other,
strategic discussions like that. There's a history of
Bill Gates not being able to download, I
don't remember if it was Windows Media Player
or some old Windows program,
and he did a
detailed step-by-step explaining why the
experience was terrible and why
they had to improve it. So I
think that kind of thing is super cool. Let's go
to the products of the week
[Music]
Let's go then, start there, Artur, what was
your product of the last week? Man, I
'm very Olympic. So, very
Olympic, the products I
used the most, including several people who
put here the products I
used the most in the last few days. Uh, man, it
was the part of...  PES from Globo Esport is about to
start, it's medals here,
medals to be played,
lost, won, and stuff,
and the YouTube mosaic part,
which you and other people
also
sent, man, and pulling mine here, there's no way it can be anything other than
the YouTube mosaic on Casé TV. I
wanted to leave my hug and
thanks, Wesley. Thank you for
making this possible because, man, it's
my conversation there, Wesley
Miss. These are people we know
here who work at YouTube Live,
and when this happened, my question
was how do I add more
mosaics here, how do I put
all possible broadcasts on this?
Because for someone passionate about
sports, this Olympic season
is wonderful, and not having to keep
changing channels, zapping around, or having
one thing on the computer, one
thing on the TV, one thing on the cell phone, one
thing on the tablet is wonderful. So, the
YouTube mosaic on Casé TV, and I'm
also using the Olympics app a lot
to see the schedule of things, it
's usually the one that has the most
accurate schedule, so for me to plan...  It's the
hours I have to wake up and stuff, uh,
I'm using the Olympics app a lot.
And then there was a... I'm going to take this opportunity to
mention the people who sent
Olympic products here, right? So
Nana sent Casé TV, Dan Leire sent
Globo Esporte and Olympics,
Bruno sent YouTube. So I'll assume
here that he's also watching the
Olympics on YouTube. So these were
the people who are in the
Olympic spirit, Team Brazil spirit with us, that's it.
And there were some others here besides
those from the team. Marina sent Wi-Fi and
Nomad, she talked about using it around the time,
so I also used Nomad in the
last few weeks. Look, the app is
very good by the way.
Andrezão sent a
board game, the second time I've sent a
game, he has time to play
Potion Explosion. Glau sent one from
Bradesco Saúde, he said that the reimbursement is
working very well. Lucas sent one
from Celina and said
that the experience is also very good.
And you skipped it, Mateus
sent NordVPN PR, but Mateus,
he's VPN, I was  With him using this
because it was PR, people see, that's it, that's
it, including a big hug here
for Mateus and Silvinha who
welcomed us and for Bela too,
who is about to be born, she'll be born a
little before, and they've already been to the movies
together, they'll be little friends, when they're
born they'll be little girls in the womb. That's
it, keep sending us
your products of the week every week, this
week there's still the Olympics, so there will be a
lot of YouTube, Casé TV, mosaic, Globo esportiva
out there, and let's see if we get some
gold medals, right? Some medals will come, and
may we
and the judges cheat a little in
our favor too, right? Because damn, we're
only getting one, man, competitions with judges
are very tough, man, I feel all the
people are experiencing what the
people who like skateboarding already experienced, even before
skateboarding was an Olympic sport, for a
long time, which is that to
beat an American, brother, in a
sport that has judges, you have to be
three times better than the American,
so years ago, seeing Luan Oliveira against
Nadia Hillston, a great
skateboarding battle that we lost.  Several were
stolen there, but more
medals are coming, it's
[Music]
that's it, so that's it, another episode.
Don't forget to leave your five
stars here, add it to your
playlist, share it with your friends,
follow us on social media, both
on Instagram and Twitter, on
LinkedIn @ @arena @art close comk
@x and that's it, we'll bump into each other
anytime. Oh, comment there, comment on
the programs, people, you don't just give likes, you don't
just give five stars, leave a
comment, we want to know what
you're enjoying, what you
want to see more suggestions. So there are a
lot of places to comment, there's
Instagram, there's LinkedIn, there's Spotify, there's
YouTube, there's Substack, there's
no shortage of places to comment on the internet, so comment there,
send it to us, and that's it. Next week
I want more comments, we're going to
read the
comments of the week, that's it, so until
next week, until next week my friend, thank
you.